[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à tunis mohamed yazid ministre de
l'information du fln a lu aux
journalistes communiqué de tripoli n'en
attend c'est le terme des communiqués le
gpr à pour poursuivre les négociations
en cours
[Musique]
alger cependant de nouveaux attentats
d'importantes mesures d'ordre était
prise la ville était totalement
quadrillé par la troupe la surveillance
quotidienne été renforcée
[Musique]
et alger connaissait la grève des
postiers il fallait après s'être soumis
à la fouille venir retirer son courrier
dans les centres de distribution
installée dans les cinémas
[Musique]
l'armée poursuit sa mission et ses
forces en multipliant les contrôles de
prévenir ou de limiter les actes de
terrorisme
ce matin-là alger a été brusquement
arrachés au sommeil par une série de
violentes déflagrations
plus de 120 explosions se sont succédé
aux quatre coins de la ville et les
dégâts matériels ont été considérables
une forte charge de plastique a détruit
le câble de retenue du téléphérique dont
la cabine a fait une chute vertigineuse
de 400 m
[Musique]
en déclenchant ce feu roulant de
plasticages low as at elle voulu
entreprendre une nouvelle et
spectaculaire action d'intimidation
auprès de la population algéroise
[Musique]
pas de vrai triomphe aux états unis sans
la consécration de new york john glenn à
la tête des six cosmonautes du projet
mercury a donc connu l'hommage de
broadway baptisée pour l'occasion le
chemin des astronomes
[Musique]
dans ce pays le degré de la gloire se
mesure au nombre de tonnes de papier
répandus et john glenn a tout lieu
d'être satisfait sa gloire a fait rouler
autant de tonnes de serpentins et de
bois déchiqueté que celle de ligne
verdun avait obtenu 35 ans plus tôt
1750 tonnes
1927 lindbergh avait réussi le premier
vol sans escale new york paris 1962
glenn a réussi un périple de trois tours
de terre il n'est sans doute pas
indifférent que les deux hommes est
déchaîné un égal enthousiasme après ceux
de gagarine et de titeuf en tout cas les
lauriers de glenn qui a ajouté à sa
panoplie de médailles celle de la ville
de new york n'ont pas fini d'en pêcher
les jeunes de dormir
[Musique]
l'un de ces jeunes justement jean louis
sartoux vient de se signaler tout
spécialement l'attention des foules à la
suite d'expériences balistique mener
secrètement dans un pavillon de la
région parisienne mauvaise mise au point
toujours est il que sa dernière
expérience peut se résumer ainsi ils
voulaient expédié s'est refusé dans la
lune il n'a réussi qu'à envoyer son père
à l'hôpital monsieur sartoux père
metteur en scène de théâtre de semble
cependant avoir gardé aucune amertume de
sa collaboration malheureuse vous avez
été imprudents
un peu plus prudent
je ferai attention double non attends
père est également propriétaire je
retourne pas qu'il fasse sauter la
maison mais
on recommencera
à un certain moment de l'année tous les
astrologues vous le diront le soleil
quitte le signe des poissons pour celui
du bélier le calendrier les approuvent
c'est ce qu'on appelle le printemps on
le reconnaît du reste à certains signes
le jardinier se plante soudain immobile
devant le premier bourgeon l'homme des
villes s'arrête lui devant les vitrines
de graines et d'outils de jardinage
cherchant le râteau ou labège de ses
rêves enfantins
est ce la proche du terme mais la
concierge arbore un nouveau sourire et
les chaises des parcs publics se
retrouvent sonata 2 à vue l'homme pour
qui les jours sont atrocement quotidien
se sentent une âme meneur et s'aperçoit
soudain qu'il a absolument besoin de
rectifier son noeud papillon il saute
avec une parfaite netteté que la chance
l'accompagnent
et que rien désormais ne peut l'empêcher
de gagner le gros lot d'un million et
demi de nouveaux francs de la tranche de
printemps justement
labertit l'au-delà grosses sociétés
pétrolières votée par dix ans de
soumission inconditionnelle sa vie ce
qu'elle ne peut plus attendre un jour de
plus pour mettre une robe légère
[Musique]
mais les robes légères attire le regard
et desquels apparaissent au dehors gare
aux conséquences que cela comporte pour
les automobilistes
le printemps on vous dit
[Musique]
la récente affaire engelvin et ses
rebondissements successifs ont ramené la
tension sur le trafic de la branche
chacun sait quelque chose de profits
réside dans ces petits paquets de poudre
blanche qui s'échange sous le manteau
contre de gros billets à 20 milles et
même à 50 mille anciens francs le gramme
le bénéfice est énorme
l'héroïne est donc une gigantesque
affaire pour les gangs qui la
commercialise
c'est pourquoi lé interpol l'organisme
international qui regroupe toutes les
polices du monde réserve dans son
répertoire du crime une place de choix à
ce qu'il est convenu d'appeler les
trafiquants de neige combien dans cet
énorme fichier qui comporte quelque cent
cinquante mille noms et marjo
fantastique bénéfices que rapporte ce
vice dont l'exploitation a suscité la
croissance d'une industrie à l'échelle
du monde
[Musique]
la carte de l'interpol invite que le
centre de la chine demeure semble-t-il
avec ses dix-sept mille hectares de
pavot le grand producteur d'opium cet
opium est dirigée sur hong kong plaque
tournante du trafic qui chaque année on
voit passer entre ces bicoques
surpeuplées et cessant pas pourri 300
tonnes de quoi fabriquer 20 tonnes
d'héroïne
dont hong kong au moyen-orient la route
de l'opium est relativement ouverte
c'est à partir de cet endroit qu'elle
devient plus surveillé est moins sûr
pour le trafiquant
car c'est point d'aboutissement se
trouvent surtout en espagne et en france
que l'interpol définit comme le centre
des officines de transformation de
l'opium en héroïne
dans les banlieues des grandes villes
sous des apparences banale se dessinait
de petits laboratoires clandestins qui
prête la drogue de façon certes
artisanale mais à tout prendre efficace
et qui tire de 15 kilos d'opium un kilo
d'héroïne
récemment la brigade des stupéfiants
n'at-elle pas pensé trouver dans les
communs du château d'augerville la
rivière l'un de ses laboratoires secrets
consacré au culte de la drogue edward
dans son propriétaire le docteur coop
ici entre deux policiers au lieu d'un
paisible chercheur scientifique qu'il
prétend être l'un de ces fabricants du
terrible poison ce poisson ne reste en
france que pour une quantité infime
c'est l'amérique qui en fait la plus
grosse consommation c'est donc la route
des états unis que surveille plus
spécialement la police paquebot luxueux
ou cargo vulgaire peuvent recéler temps
de recoins discret tant de possibles
cachette malgré tout la drogue arrive
encore trop souvent et la chaîne du
trafic s'étire en toile d'araignée sur
le pays entier il n'est pas rare de voir
la brigade des stupéfiants saisir ici et
là un stock d'héroïne coffret un
trafiquant mais le gang de la drogue
n'était lasse pas encore décapité
[Musique]
c'est championnats du monde de ski au
tremplin de 90 m à zakopane en pologne
ce concurrent nous invite à faire le
saut avec lui
[Musique]
et
je donne l'impression d'un oiseau il ne
semble pas qu'il est à faire des efforts
pour conserver son équilibre un sauteur
c'est aussi presque une fusée une fusée
qui éclatent parfois avant d'atteindre
son but
[Musique]
les uns après les autres tous ses
concurrents s'offrent des vols planés de
près de 100 m
c'est également vrai que nagl qui va le
plus loin il atteint 103 m
[Musique]
et par la même occasion il obtient le
titre de champion du monde
[Musique]